[Music]
new rules regarding guns on movie sets
were proposed guess why because alex
he's innocent dude he didn't do anything
he didn't do it you think he didn't do
anything pull the trigger i don't even
think he was in the room
i don't think he was in the same state
no i don't think he would do that but i
do think he's a murderer
i think he's like
just like [ __ ] bruce lee's kid i
didn't know that we were gonna uh debate
the actual existence of him being on set
i don't even think that alan baldwin is
real no no conspiracy now we're talking
about now we're talking that could make
sense you think any of the baldwins are
real you know baldwin the baldwin family
is a really rich family in hawaii i
can't prove it
i don't know the other names
i don't know so what about these gun
rules huh wait what are they what are
the other baltimore alec
billy alec billy
wasn't he on like uh entertainment
tonight
billy baldwin was on entertainment
tonight that's a snowball fact
i was on entertainment tonight yeah as a
guest at least once
that also sounds important
these are successful board names yeah
so yeah ever since the accident that
happened on the set of rust they tried
to propose some new laws to make uh
having guns on set even safer
but um it's pretty safe though if you
have someone who's competent okay you
would think you would think right
all right but both of the proposals
failed to pass legislation so nothing's
changing
good news sick sick update we had one
that's for lunch
we had a guy on set he was uh what do
you call it the the the the fireman
that's what they call the fireman the
fireman
man the fire marshall man there's more
than one we talked about the bachelor
party who was that last week no he
there's a name for it there's like a
prop man master or if there's a group of
them it's a flock there's a name there's
a [ __ ] official the armor armor armor
okay mr armor the gun master the gunman
next to the beast master and then
he so when i was on set at night okay
believe it or not i'm a movie star i was
there and then i was the star of the
show and then he came up and he goes
ladies and gentlemen
uh can i have your attention before we
shoot i need to do this uh safety
precaution here is the gun right here it
is a real gun but uh it takes real
bullets this is like when i'm in the
airplane i'm like yeah
yeah okay yeah i think i don't know the
gun works thank you
and he put it all the rules all right
and then everyone had to pay attention
and he goes only the actor and me can
shoot it which is me i was the actor and
then he's like
make sure you don't point it at anybody
and then i had to [ __ ] shoot somebody
but he goes don't actually aim at them
point to the side dude how do they do
that in john wick that guy [ __ ]
dude everyone
every minute he's pointing everything
point blank
to the head he's putting his mouth put
up a [ __ ] dose
if you look it's really just out his
mouth a little bit out of it
moving magic steve
the bad boys of choreography all right
yeah but it's piano
i think he gets special treatment
because it's keanu i think he gets to
use a real gun that's a gun reform lot
it's like nobody can do this except
keanu oh that's fair well that dude
trains like a [ __ ] and he takes
the taxi at new york's in new york he
doesn't even in fight club at the end
when ed norton has the gun in his mouth
if you turn it's really just back here
holy [ __ ] every time they put they're
putting gun in the mouth of the movie
it's actually just
they're not supposed to
it's one of these surreal gun but it's a
prop mouth
it's a prosthetic mouth this is a
[ __ ] sex toy
it's a fleshlight mouth it's a prop head
it's a prop whole person yeah with live
ammo what the [ __ ]
it makes a lot of sense but the arms of
the actor but you need it for the shot
though save money on the vfx yeah
because when this gun fires you don't
have to do anything to the vfx right
just the whole person
yeah you just have to make it
gonna
on camera i'm cutting my hand right now
but i'm really this oh
see movie magic that looks good don't
believe everything you see in hollywood
all you really need is this uh
cinematographer's version of got your
nose
that's really all it takes
it's
these are all the knives on set this is
the this is what's really happening
they tried to pass that law but it
failed yeah they tried to pass that law
no it seemed like it was a lot of common
sense things like uh like
kind of just making everything more
difficult to do but i think the the main
idea that everybody had with being
against it was that it wouldn't really
protect productions that were taking
place out of state so they were like
well there's no point people are just
going to find other ways to do it but
the people who are already following the
rules will just have a harder time to
spend more money we'll have to get more
certification it just makes it harder
for people that are doing
i guess it's harder to do anything it
kind of just reflects what'll happen
with um with guns anyway like you know
like with uh
everything that's going on with banning
guns or making guns harder to get
everyone who's law-abiding already will
have a harder time anyone's already a
criminal or you know an out there anyway
it doesn't change for them right right
yeah i got lit on fire one time for a
movie it was sick really yeah
they leave me on fire how long were you
on fire for i was on fire for like
probably 25 minutes
it's a big body though
live fire no i saw yeah when i saw that
picture of that guy who's sitting there
he's like on fire yeah i was like the
gandhi guy yeah yeah i mean the monk
yeah yeah yeah that dude wait why did
you have to be on fire i was for there's
a bit for this movie i did but but yeah
they hid the light part of my body on
fire like my whole arm was on fire and
they actually did it which is super sick
they tell you they gel you up and they
hot they put this like sleeve oh you
don't feel it but there's a certain
point that like once you feel it being
even warm that's when you call it
and then
and then you call it can we do that
today we sure can i actually brought
some with me
so this is actually just gasoline i've
been drinking gasoline this entire time
just fire gel fly your chip did you feel
the heat on your face yeah you could
feel it you could feel it like a
radiating from it but it definitely is
an eerie thing because it's like it's
almost like a graphic effect you don't
believe that it's actually happening
live watching cg yeah cause you should
be feeling it hot but it's not what you
felt
yeah it's crazy what were some of the
character choices you decided to do as a
man with his arm as a man
and then we'll get to you as well yeah
as a woman though how did it feel for
you we'll go back we'll go back
i was trying to give out a lot of very
hot high fives
so that was
the high five is a really good concept i
like that and now as a ph balanced how
did it feel
were you on fire too for your thing i'm
always on fire
[Music]
it's very brave of you very brave
what did you have to do it for what was
it like uh um um
my ex was a stuntman and he did a lot of
fire stunts so we just light each other
on fire i remember that's just that's
how you express love
tell us about these uh fires yeah i saw
these players there was a stun dude like
from the distance of me and nick and i
he was on fire the whole [ __ ] body
right like he was on a [ __ ] suit that
[ __ ] was so hot i could feel it from
here and i was like damn i should be
back more imagine what that guy feels
yeah
he probably is that nothing no no
imagine what he feels
that told me empathy bro
inside that [ __ ] is a beast
i don't think i believe you but i
believed everything she said you know
why because we [ __ ] believe all women
this side of the room we believe all
that's what we do here not those guys
over there
not those guys that's what we do
definitely should not
have way too much leverage you guys
believe more women than cheetos by the
way whoa
so you're not an ally let's talk about
this oh i don't know what to do yeah how
do we pander
um
wait wait on fire though yeah burn
yourselves guys
we've heard of that yeah we'll go we'll
go there yeah
do you think do you think you would
enjoy would you guys enjoy a scene like
that two guys doing jiu jitsu on fire
yeah i think that's one of the only ways
to make it sometimes as a jesus
practitioner i think that's not
realistic
you can't you can't start there right
away you know that's got to be like fast
and furious seven you gotta let this
thing escalate two this guy's on fire
imagine if it started there first
opening scene
it was like
in kickboxing where he had to dip his
[ __ ]
but then they're upping the stakes for
jiu jitsu they're like i'm gonna light
myself on fire you're gonna light
yourself on fire dip your whole body in
glass yeah
and then you roll around
glass first then the glue yeah
there's no glass suit though you just
start bleeding yeah yeah they both got a
first roll in the glue and then the
glass and all that but they're going to
get stuck together
they're going to get stuck first it's
kind of a dream though kind of a dream
for just flipped upside down
just glue no glass and you guys are
stuck yeah yeah what's your dream scene
if you were playing a jiu jitsu guy what
is your dream [ __ ] scene and then
we'll see if you dip both guys in
different colors of paint then they do
it all on the canvas and then you try to
sell that [ __ ] after so you profit from
every angle oh [ __ ]
that's the next level
yeah that's in the movie i'm into that
it's like you know what this actually is
it's a depiction of deduction
yeah that's the entire [ __ ] doctor
let's do this at the chocolate factory
these guys are on the rail they're
fighting they fall into the chocolate
[ __ ] machine off the balcony and they
get back up we're fighting for the gun
and then now they got a jujitsu with
chocolate all over their body on canvas
and then they sell the canvas after and
the chocolate but if they're in the
chocolate they would just drown because
you just is all on the ground yeah so
are the enemies by the time they're
selling the [ __ ] art no no [ __ ] that
this is what we do we do jiu jitsu style
but then
attitude
okay attitude
[ __ ] tables chairs ladders i'm
already in it that's it so jiu-jitsu so
no pain
meets wwe no merch no pain no chocolate
no chocolate just [ __ ] steel chairs
would you dude wwe that about twisted
steel and sex appeal
jitsu on top of a steel cage on top
you're a little too progressive here i
don't think anyone gives a [ __ ]
all the cameras are below the steel cage
sounds like there's a jiu jitsu guys in
the roof there's like a lot of rattling
up there hey keep it down
what are you gonna do with your
gentleman
that's how they should do that's a new
angle of jiu-jitsu have you ever been to
the [ __ ] uh glass tunnel at the mgm
where you could see the [ __ ] lines
and [ __ ] so you do the jiu jitsu up
there and then the audience at the
bottom that's actually kind of tight the
event's called eyes shut yeah
so you watch the jiu jitsu like this
that's actually kind of you never
thought of that
nobody watches jiu jitsu at high level
anyway no one's going to [ __ ] want to
look up to watch what if they're all
lying down though it's like more
convenient oh yeah unless you do jujitsu
you don't give a [ __ ] honestly
and that's the first barrier of
jiu-jitsu that makes sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you